hey I'm Doug Walker from channel awesome
at the end of our most popular show
nostalgia critic we always do a charity
shout-out encouraging people to donate
well they've done well we realize not
everybody's in a financial situation
where they can give but everybody at
some point or another can give time so
every month we're gonna try and show a
new charity or organization that you can
help out with there's so many people in
difficult circumstances but thankfully
there's always people who are willing to
help and you can be one of them whether
it's volunteering or lending a helping
hand we're here to show you what you can
do I'm here at Hollywood Beach in
Chicago Illinois it's been downpouring
on and off all day it's gone from a
drizzle to some really intense rain
nobody in the right mind will be out
here except for people who care and the
right thing
are you aware my name is Tyrone Dobson
and I'm the volunteer manager for the
Alliance for the Great Lakes and what do
you guys doing out here today we're
doing a beach cleanup today so we do our
adoptive each program is one of our
longest running programs we serve as
fifteen thousand volunteers each year
and those volunteers last year picked up
thirty six thousand pounds of trash and
so they're doing work all over the Great
Lakes so in all eight states that border
the Great Lakes we have volunteers
cleaning up all year long so starting
somewhere in like March or April and
running all the way through September
October when we came here today you're
like man the weather I don't know if
anyone's gonna show up to this we're
vote can't look each other give him the
worried eyes but like people showed up I
mean and the weather is just miserable
today how does that make you feel when
you see people say no I'm gonna come out
here I'm gonna help anyway it kind of
gives you a sense of pride because you
see your city coming together to really
make good work we were sitting here
we're like oh man if the weather is so
crappy it's kind of rainy and then out
of nowhere 20 people showed up and it
was almost like I blinked in them there
they were so it gives me a lot of pride
in my position to know that I'm helping
people come out and do this type of work
and they're doing a lot not only to help
the actual city so that the beach gets
cleaned up but we're also doing great
work for the things that can't advocate
for themselves like the wildlife in the
area or even the small children that
come out with their families to recreate
on the beach this is our drinking water
rent there's so much crud in there and
it needs to be looked after it needs to
be accounted for the Great Lakes
services a lot of people and it impacts
more people than what they actually know
so one in ten Americans and one in four
Canadians get their drinking water from
the Great Lakes it's always better if
that water doesn't have tiny pieces of
plastic or other debris floating in it
before it gets treated so that we can
drink it Discovery Channel Shark Week
what are you doing here we're here
hoping to clean up some beaches and you
know spread a little bit of awareness
Ocean Conservancy
is a huge part of Shark Week every year
obviously we really care about
conserving the world's oceans and you
know giving back to the community and
Shark Week is an awesome fun program and
it's our 30th anniversary this year this
is definitely a huge part of what Shark
Week is meant to do is to kind of bring
awareness about what's going on in the
world in terms of the ocean how cool is
it have Discovery Channel here I mean
it's super exciting when they reached
out to us and said you know hey Shark
Week is happening I'm like there's no
there's no sharks in the Great Lakes but
hey we're happy to make we're happy to
have you out today we do have Asian carp
potentially and other invasive species
in the Great Lakes so we want to make
sure that you know we call attention to
our own priorities we also are happy to
have them on board - how does it make
you feel when you see like people come
out and actually like you know try to
try to clean up and make the beaches
better and Great Lakes and all that
stuff maybe well what goes through your
mind when you see that kind of stuff I
mean I just wished that more people
would do that it makes us happy from you
know a network standpoint to see that
our programming can help inspire people
to get out there and give back to the
community and you know make the world a
better place one beach cleanup at a time
we have got only Discovery Channel here
today but also the Ocean Conservancy and
they help us all throughout the year I
mean they're our partners in our in the
International Coastal Cleanup efforts
that we are a part of I'm here in
Chicago so we're happy to have all of
our partners here today know why there's
no sharks because you clean them out
there you just keep them out there
cranking them out you know one by one
not everybody that comes out here to
help clean is necessary part of an
organization they just do it because
they want to help like this dude here
who we literally just ran into tell me
about what it is you do and why you do
it okay hi my name is ricardo santos
Hernandez I'm a Chicago artist my dog
Mannion
I come every morning pick up trash and
we focus mostly on plastic plastic that
floats onto the beach I feel overwhelmed
because there is so much trash and
plastic that I get very upset there's so
many people that leave this stuff and
it's just lost just one thing but it
adds up and it can really really do a
lot of damage yes those days and I pick
up for the four bags I can only imagine
what the rest of their life is life you
turn that into art yes what I do is I'm
working on a series for Smithsonian
Institute
it's a waterways exhibit little
confirmation why that is my goal is to
show what's happening here locally and
I'm using all these found objects and
pieces of plastic and trash in my
artwork the hope is that when I exhibit
these pieces to raise awareness of
that doesn't make you feel good knowing
there's other people makes me feel good
so when I was walking up the ramp and
sighs Ocean Conservancy that made me
very excited you know we were saying
before a lot of people don't always see
this is like an urgent matter but again
when this stuff builds up and people
don't don't come together and don't do
what you're doing here today it can be
urgent it can have a really bad impact
on me I talked to a volunteer once
before when I first started at the
Alliance I said why do you do what you
do and the person said well if you see a
wildfire and you know that something bad
has happened because the ground is black
and it's charred the lakes don't
necessarily have the same type of effect
so it always looks kind of good but
unbeknownst to the naked eye there are
things that are going on they're not
necessarily always great that are
happening things like invasive species
or tiny pieces of trash that are
floating in the water that you can't see
or the fact that cigarette butts are
kind of the same color is sand it might
not look like it's dirty but I guarantee
you today will pick up over a hundred
pounds of debris off the beach today
we're hoping to make a healthy Great
Lakes for today tomorrow and forever I
can't tell you how many volunteers I run
into they said my family used to have a
beach house on Lake Michigan and I want
to make sure that we're always able to
go out there and have a great time like
I did as a kid and I think that's the
that's the heart of this we want to make
sure that generations can enjoy this
wonderful resource forever
and I think that the work of these
volunteers today and work of volunteers
throughout the entire season meet that
need obviously we're seeing a great
example here people picking up how can
people volunteer outside of just going
to the beach and cleaning up and stuff
I'm assuming there's a lot of various
ways they can help out there's a lot of
ways you can get involved with the
Alliance so of course there's the actual
like boots on the ground adoptive each
program but outside of that we also do a
lot of work in the policy space so I
would encourage anyone that wants to
take us take action to go on our website
Great Lakes org and sign up to receive
our emails what we do is we send out
things called action alerts so if
there's some type of legislation that
needs the support of a senator or needs
a support of a representative this is
the issue that's happening and you
should contact your local rep
or your local senator to sell them to
support this action it's as simple as
putting your name down on a form online
it's super easy it's an easy way to get
back that way
I mean it's great to see people going
out there and thinking up stuff but
people want volunteer in a different way
it's as easy just going online just
going on a computer right I want to make
it an option for people to connect
whether they can make their way out to
the beach or whether they cannot and no
matter which way they get involved with
us it's all good in our eyes so just
this stretch out to other areas outside
of Chicago absolutely so I any given day
we have a beach cleanup happening at
somewhere in the Great Lakes there's not
a day that goes by and especially in the
summer that there's not a cleanup going
on so we have cleanups you know way up
in Duluth oh we're in Buffalo New York
and everywhere in between so every day
there's a beach cleanup happening
somewhere that there's very rarely is it
that we don't have anything happening on
a day so it definitely keeps them busy
but we're happy to facilitate that type
of work but that's also a lot of work
for volunteers to come in and do stuff
and I mean that's fantastic event
there's something every day that's every
day the best part about it for me is I
encourage people to get out because
there's no better way to get to enjoy
the beach and to see different areas and
to go to all of these things so the
beach in Duluth the beach in superior a
beach in Cleveland a beach in Detroit
all of those look different and it's a
different experience for the volunteer
so I encourage everyone to get out and
try different locations and go to
different beaches I think that's the
best part about this opportunity is that
you get like a built-in vacation almost
in it when the weather is really nice
there's nothing better than going and
like hanging out on the beach it's
actually really clean after you doing a
lot of great work yeah there's gotta be
a good feeling when you come in and you
pick up stuff you do some work and then
you're like I'm at the beach while they
just lie down go swim in the water and
it's in a beach that you know you help
keep clean I mean it's gotta be a good
feeling it's a good feeling and I
guarantee you it happens all
and I see it so people will come in in
their swim trunks or their amazing suits
and they'll do the beach cleanup and
then as we wrap everything up they're
picking up clothes and they go and jump
in the lake so I don't think there's a
better way to into volunteering
activities than that in my opinion if
you learned right right I earned this
relaxation and that's this is my reward
today sometimes I go and stick my toes
in the water as well so I can't I can
say I'm part of that as well well I want
you to look at that camera there I want
you to tell the people if they want to
donate volunteer or just check out we
guys are about where can you go online
you can go online to wwatling org to be
connected with the Alliance for the
Great Lakes hope to see you soon awesome
thank you so much man thank you for what
you're doing hey no problem
[Music]
[Laughter]
you